fashion is one of the fastest growing
industries on the planet
around the world 80 billion new pieces
of clothing are sold every year
400 more than just 40 years ago
americans alone are buying five times
more garments than in 1980.
now a 1.3 trillion dollar mega industry
fashion employs more than 300 million
people worldwide
while other industries have come a part
of the seams clothing production has
doubled in the last 15 years
but it's a fashion statement with a
steep environmental price tag
making one kilogram of fabric produces
23 kilograms of greenhouse gases
textile production generates more carbon
dioxide than all international flights
and maritime shipping combined
yet half of all clothes are thrown away
within one year
many having never been worn
fashion is now considered the second
most polluting industry in the world
after oil
and with increasing middle classes in
the developing world keen to make their
own fashion statement this will get
worse
if 80 of emerging markets reach western
levels of clothes shopping carbon
dioxide emissions could increase by
nearly 80 percent per person
by 2050
total clothing sales could reach 175
million tons
turning the planet into the biggest
fashion victim of them all
[Music]
you